The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: This video
that we saw by David Mindell
is about his new
book, which is called
Our Robots Ourselves, Robots
and the Myth of Autonomy.
And he means exactly that.
Autonomy really is a
myth and will be so.
And David has a unique
perspective on this question,
because this is his life.
In other words, he has
been deeply involved
with robotics at just
cutting-edge levels
for the last 30-plus years.
So he was deeply involved in
a lot of the early undersea
exploration and working
with Bob Ballard and Alvin
and the pods that
came off Alvin.
And then he did a
lot of work with NASA
and was involved in
the robotics on Mars
and the planetary
explorations using robotics.
And then he spent a lot of
time with the US military
that had been doing
drone technology
and has a real hands-on feel.
He's also a pilot and
flies extensively,
both helicopters and aircraft.
He's been involved in a
helicopter-drone company,
so he knows exactly what
those are and how they work.
And in addition, he's
just taken leave from MIT,
and he set up his own robotics
company, including with people
from Lincoln Labs, which has
the greatest radar expertise.
And the issue there
is, how do you
create robots that can work
in really intimate proximity
with people, right?
Not kind of arm's length
distance, much less
locked in on a floor, but
really in close proximity.
So they're developing
interesting technologies
to enable that.
So he's got a whole personal
sense of what this robotics
movement is all about.
And he kind of takes us back
from the literature that
has portrayed this kind of
ongoing nightmare of job
displacement from robotics,
and I think, frankly,
puts us in a much more realistic
posture of what it's actually
going to be like when robotics
start to scale up to a greater
extent than they have so far.
And his work-- we read JCR
Licklider when we took up
the book The Dream Machine,
his biography by Mitch Waldrop.
And Licklider, as
you remember, gave us
this picture of how
people and machines were
going to work together.
And Licklider, in a
way, was responding
to a period of
technological concern
that computers were going to
replace people, because they
could think better than people.
And Licklider, although
a great technologist,
was trained as a psychologist.
And his field was
man-machine interface--
how do people work
with machines?
How does that actually function?
And so he comes to computing
with this vision of a symbiosis
between, computers are going
to do what they're good at,
and people are going to
do what they're good at,
and we're going to have a
symbiosis between the two
that's going to optimize
both territories.
And indeed, that's exactly the
direction that computers go in.
In other words, I'm not
spending sleepless nights
wondering when this thing is
going to replace me, right?
We thought it was.
And Norbert Wiener
at MIT had invented
the term cybernetics and wrote
the first book on the topic.
But Wiener had a
very dark vision
of what computing
was going to be
for the future of
human thinking.
It didn't turn out to happen.
So Mindell is arguing that
even the most threatening
technology, which
arguably is robotics,
it's just not going
to work out that way.
A symbiosis is going to
be what's achieved here.
And he takes apart each one of
these territories in the book.
I mean, I had you do the video.
But it's a very rich and
very well-written book.
It's a tremendously
fun read, and he
tells a lot of great stories.
But his vision is that there
can be a richer space when
people and robots are joined.
There's a ritual
understanding and ability
to make perceptions
and judgments that
occurs from that mix.
And that turns out to be
exactly his experience undersea
and doing space robotics,
that there's just
a different kind of
environment that evolves here.
And it's better than a
machine alone or a person
alone, that there's
a new symbiosis that
enhances both sides in a
way that we can draw on.
And what he finds is that
when people, in effect,
start to operate the robotics--
and in the end,
in these systems,
autonomous systems
don't work very well--
people really need to be part
of the process with the robot--
that the robot becomes an
extension of themselves.
And that, in fact, all their
perceptions are in the robot.
So even if the robot is
a mile deeper undersea
or tens of thousands
of miles away in space
running around the moon, that
the person operating the robot
and cooperating with the
robot is in the robot.
And the sensory systems that
are available to the robot
really become theirs.
In effect, we get extended
with a whole new kind of reach.
And that's really his
vision of what occurs here.
That's the UAV story, that's
the undersea exploration
story, that's the space story.
And, he argues, this is going
to be the driverless car
story, too.
So we have been proceeding--
and he goes through this at
rich length in his book--
we've been proceeding
under the assumption
that we're going to get
replaced by driverless cars.
But he argues, wait a minute, 40
years of experience of robotics
says that's not what happens.
Instead, this symbiosis
starts to occur, right?
Because people are not
going to want to give up
certain kinds of
level of controls
and certain kinds
of decision-making.
They're going to want
to be involved in those.
So he argues, that just as
with undersea exploration
and with the other robotics
fields that he's talking about,
a richer driver experience
that involves much more
engagement with the
surroundings, much
greater information and
knowledge access, much
better safety and much better
comfort, a lower stress
environment, can occur in
a driverless car setting.
That people will still
be in command of the car.
They'll be able to cede a
lot of lower-end territory
to the robotic
activities, but will
retain certain kinds
of charge and be
able to operate in a different
kind of level of perception.
We'll see, you know?
Time will tell here.
The driverless car
movement has been
pushed by a whole
community that assumes
that he wants to get
people out of the driver's
seat into the trunk,
or at least watching
movies in the back seat.
Mindell argues that's actually
probably not going to occur.
And then he lays out a series
of technological challenges
that have to happen.
So LIDAR, which is the
fundamental radar system we're
using for driverless cars--
and David knows a
lot about radar,
because that's what
his new company is
organizing right now--
LIDAR happens to be very
problematic in wet surfaces
and snowy services.
It fails, right?
That's why Google has based its
driverless car operation out
in sunny California, right?
Uber is having much more
trouble in Pittsburgh.
And I'm sure your
friends, Steph,
are going to have
trouble when they worry
about Boston in the wintertime
with their driverless car
initiatives.
It's highly problematic.
You can get around that by using
ground-penetrating radar, which
avoids the surface water problem
and surface slickness problem.
But at the moment, that's
another $70,000 per car.
So the prices will get
driven down the cost curve,
and maybe we can do that.
But these are significant
barriers here.
I was at a presentation
recently by Gill Pratt and John
Leonard, who are leading
the Toyota driverless car
initiative.
And it was an
interesting discussion.
The leader of the discussion
said, well, you know,
we're going to have driverless
cars within five years.
And Gill Pratt,
who led the whole
robotics effort in DARPA--
and a former MIT
faculty member, one
of the most respected experts
in robotics in the world,
and named by Toyota
to lead their effort--
Gill had this line
and he said, you know,
people tend to
completely overestimate
what we're going to accomplish
in the next five years
and completely underestimate
what we're going
to accomplish in the next 50.
We're not good at
making that balance.
And in effect what
he was saying is,
the driverless car problem
is not a five-year problem.
And then John Leonard,
who is running
MIT's part of the
Toyota initiative, one
of MIT's famous robotics
experts, he put up a video.
And the video was him
taking his kids to school.
And they drive down a
residential street-- one
of these kind of urbanized
suburbs around here.
And there's a T-intersection.
So they leave the
residential street,
and they have to make a left
turn to get to the school.
The kids are
sitting in the back.
And in the lane
immediately in front of him
going in that direction,
going to the right,
are cars that are
erratically coming across
at about 40 to 50 miles an hour.
And the lane that he
wants to get into,
it's bumper to bumper,
completely stalled.
And he's got to turn left.
He finally is able to solve
the problem, he indicates,
by rolling down
his window, making
a judgment about what driver
might be the most sympathetic.
Waving, establishing
an eye contact,
and this driver
is willing to let
him pull in in front of her.
But he's then got to wait--
she's got to be at the
right point in the line,
and the erratic 50-mile-an-hour
cars have got to let up
a little bit so
he can get across.
He's finally able to achieve it.
He does this every morning.
He said, look, I can't
write the algorithm
for the left-hand turn
into heavy traffic.
I can't do it.
I've been thinking about
it for a long time.
That is at least
a 10-year problem.
How is my driverless car
going to establish eye contact
with the driver
in that far lane.
How are they going to
signal out the window?
How are they going to make
that personal connection?
All of us, when we
drive all the time,
are making constant judgments
about other drivers.
John Leonard says, I
can't write the algorithms
to evaluate the crazy
18-year-old hot rod
driver versus me versus an
elderly 65-year-old driver.
I can't make those
differentials in my algorithms
to make this thing work.
So the problem of driving
in an urbanized setting
is going to be profound.
He said, look, we can
probably figure out
interstate driving-- the
variables are much more
manageable.
But urbanized setting, it's
really, really complicated.
So I guess what
Mindell is telling us--
and those are just examples
that are not in his book,
but I'm pulling up
from recent experience.
But Mindell is telling us
that this autonomy is not
necessarily at hand.
And even when it is
available, and he
uses the example of
the moon landing,
the astronauts preempt it,
because they see things, i.e.
a small crater, that would
have prevented the landing
in the right location.
So they have to take over the
controls and move the thing.
People are not going
to want to give up
that level of involvement,
he argues, and shouldn't,
because there's
some things they're
going to be better at judging
than even the best machinery we
can come up with.
So there's an example
that David uses,
which is that a combination of
a chess master and a computer
always beats another
chess master alone
or a computer alone.
And so far, that's
our experience.
Now, all of these things
could change over time,
and technology will
definitely advance.
But what David is arguing is
that this robotics revolution
is not going to be a
revolution around autonomy.
It's going to be a revolution
like this revolution
around symbiosis.
And I think that's a really
important thing for us
to keep in mind as we
think about the speed which
these changes are going
to start to happen.
The complexity is really high.
And the nature of the
changes themselves.
And in David Mindell's world
of cobotics and assistive
robotics, there
is much more room
for people than a truly
totally autonomous system.
And that presents-- again, back
to our education discussion,
that's back to our training
discussion-- that presents
a whole new set of ways of
thinking about what this
is going to look like that we
probably ought to keep in mind.
And it also means that the
timetable of these changes
is not as abrupt as the
media has been telling us
in the last couple of years.
It's a more manageable--
David Mindell would argue--
and more gradual
kind of timetable.
All right.
Sanam, it's all yours.
SANAM: Yeah.
So I think that the question
about symbiosis between people
and machines is really
interesting, especially
considering the debate about
whether people and robots are
a lot like substitute goods
or complementary goods.
And I think that
the consensus here
is that they are
equally complementary.
But I think that also has
some interesting implications
for what that could do
to the human environment.
So even with goods
that are complementary,
it's likely that
this will push out
the demand for
the types of labor
that is more well-versed
in high skill [INAUDIBLE]
in working with these
types of technology
and reduced demand
for labor that's less.
So I think that there are
really important considerations
about when you're
integrating technology
into a human environment,
how it's going
to affect that environment.
So I think just a question
that a lot of you had was,
when you are looking at
building these autonomous or
semi-autonomous technologies
into an existing
human environment, it's going
to require a lot of knowledge
about that environment
in order to make
these important
predictive models.
So what are some of the biggest
challenges in doing that?
And where do you see the
potential failings or pitfalls?
CHLOE: So one of the things
I was interested in--
I really agree with a lot
of the points that he makes.
I think he lays out really
optimistic, but also
appropriately realistic future
for our symbiotic relationships
with robots in a lot
of different fields.
But [INAUDIBLE]
your question, he
raises the issue of the pilot,
the soldier, and the astronaut
who are all, to some extent, a
little reticent to fully adopt
complete autonomy in their
own respective fields.
So I guess one of
the places where
you could consider a potential
failure of that symbiosis
is, is that hesitation to adopt
the fully-autonomous system
something we should train
out of these humans?
Or should we adapt our
technological development
to match it?
Like is that a failure
point or is that OK?
MAX: It's possible that the want
or the desire to go away from
autonomy-- maybe they have some
sort of instinctual realization
that the computer cannot do
everything that they can.
It's not as good at
pattern recognition,
that kind of thing.
So maybe it's not
a failure point.
Maybe instead it's a--
[SNEEZING]
I'm not sure what
you would call it.
CHLOE: Interesting.
MAX: Bless you.
CHLOE: Like an actual
benefit to that.
MAX: Yeah, almost
like a warning system.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And on top of that, I feel
like there's a whole--
especially thinking
about cars, but I'm
sure for pilots and
other people as well--
there's a lot of culture
around being a driver
or being a pilot.
You can define
yourself as a pilot.
And I think by taking
away any control
that you have over an
aircraft or something, that
can be something that
people don't want
to do just because
people like to drive,
they like the open
road, they want
to feel like they're in control.
And taking that away could just
be a cultural issue as well.
RASHEED: I thought autopilot was
pretty well-accepted and kind
of integrated by now.
I know, especially for
long-distance flights,
cross-Atlantic, I
definitely don't
want the pilot of this
airplane reading and charting
the navigation across
the Atlantic Ocean.
Like, I'm good.
We can definitely have
more integrated technology
to allow machines to do that.
But at least within
the pilot community,
I thought this was
pretty accepted.
And now with fighter
pilots and things
like that, you're
going so fast, it
doesn't make sense to
have a human interpret
all these signals
that are coming in.
CHLOE: Sorry.
RASHEED: Yeah, no, go ahead.
CHLOE: No, you are right.
It is very widely
accepted and integrated.
But also, I think you make
an interesting point in terms
of how people define
themselves and that job
being actually part
of their identity.
Also, I think as we've
developed more and more complex
machines and those
machines become
integrated into our life,
we interact with each other
through those machines.
So even just taking the
example of air traffic.
There's a very complex
communication network
between air traffic controllers
and different pilots
from commercial aviation
to general aviation.
And even though that system has
a lot of autonomous components
in it in today's
day in age, there's
still generations of
protocol, both very officially
delineated and also sort
of adopted as practice.
And I think that the
humans who are willingly
part of that system as
controllers and pilots
know that very well.
And so they know how to
interact with the other pilots,
both in manners and how to make
well-informed, safe decisions
based on what other
people are doing.
So I think-- yeah.
I think that even though they
might be flying, technically,
a completely autonomous
plane, they still
serve as the end-point of the
communication with other humans
who are in charge of other
completely autonomous systems.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
And Chloe, I think
you're absolutely
right on that from what
I understand from David's
book and discussions with him.
In addition, he gives
a remarkable example.
It's a startling example
that starts the book off.
When you get a chance, the
book is really worth reading.
He tells the story of an Air
France crash over the Pacific
15 years ago.
Chloe, I see you're
smiling, so you're
thinking about the story.
CHLOE: Yeah, I was just
thinking about this.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: And
you can extrapolate and see
if I get the story right.
But essentially, the
story that he tells
is that there's a moment in the
flight they're on autopilot.
As you point out,
Rasheed, it can
be a very useful tool
for pilots and is
used in many parts
of a flight pattern.
And they're on
autopilot, and the plane
enters an area of very
low temperatures and ice
is forming on the wings.
So the autopilot system default
mechanism, at that point,
is to remove the
autopilot control
and switch it to
the pilot control.
And what has happened is that
the pilot of the aircraft
is back in the restroom,
because they're on autopilot
over the middle of the Pacific.
And the engineer, the flight
engineer and the co-pilot,
are at the controls.
They're relaxing.
And suddenly, they're in charge.
And each has a
different reaction.
And it ends up completely
destabilizing the aircraft
and throwing it into a spin
right into the Pacific Ocean,
where all the lives
and aircraft are lost.
And they had the opposite--
they're not ready.
So this moment of people being
ready to take control again
after having been out
of control turns out
to be a nightmare in all kinds
of other settings, right?
It's very unmanageable.
How do you keep the person who
needs to be in overall control
completely in the game?
And how do you keep them
completely involved?
So that's one of the
most complicated design
problems for autonomous
vehicles in general,
and driverless
cars in particular.
Since we're probably not going
to get to fully driverless cars
soon, how is that
relationship going to work?
And how are we going
to play that out?
And how do you keep just
enough of a level involved?
And interesting, Rasheed,
back to your point,
the autopilot system in aircraft
has actually now evolved
to the point where
they keep that balance
right between the
machine and the person
and the overall
person in control
and the desire of the person
to retain the control.
They figured out
what the signaling
is so that that actually
works well on both sides.
But that's a really complicated
balance to work out.
Have I got that right,
Chloe, would you say?
CHLOE: Yeah, yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Anything
you have to say more on this?
Are you studying this?
CHLOE: Well, in AeroAstro
we do a little bit
of failure investigation.
But I also fly
personally, and I've
had a lot of experiences that
validate that exact thing.
So I used to fly a pretty
small four-seater aircraft.
MAX: Cessna?
CHLOE: Yeah, well,
a Columbia, which
is basically the same size as
a Cessna, but a lot faster.
And I used to fly
with my dad a lot.
And one of the stories that
we would repeatedly live out
when we were landing at a
new airport was that the air
traffic controller would,
based on the size and type
of our aircraft, would
vastly underestimate
the speed at which we
were making our descent.
And a full descent into
most of these airports
is a multi-leg
type thing, but you
start up to 20 minutes before
you're actually on the ground.
So it's pretty complicated.
There are other
airplanes in the air.
You have to match their
speeds and rates of descent,
so you don't have two people
colliding on the runway.
And repeatedly, how fast we were
going would be underestimated.
And we would be coming down
much more rapidly than the air
traffic controller would think.
And so we'd be going faster
than a much, much larger
aircraft was.
So that was just another
case of where establishing
that human contact
with other people
to let them know where you
were and with the people whose
instrumentation was telling
them something different,
it's important to have people
who know their own missions--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Interesting example.
CHLOE: --involved
in the process.
MARTIN: I think there's also an
opportunity for using autonomy
in an area where
there's human bias.
There was a case study of
a Japanese flight, where
the co-pilot knows that what the
actual pilot is doing is wrong.
But because he's an
authority figure,
he won't contradict them.
So using some autonomous things
to say like, no, this is wrong,
we're definitely doing
something wrong, or at least
put some kind of flag is useful.
In sci-fi, it was
really cool, because it
talked about human
bias injustice,
like when you make a decision.
And so there was this
one science fiction
where in the future,
an AI was the judge,
because he'd be non-biased.
I don't know.
I think that stuff's
pretty interesting.
AUDIENCE: That's already
kind of happening,
that they've been
using algorithms
in some jurisdictions
to determine
whether someone should
get bail or not based
on their backgrounds.
It's like a
proprietary software,
which is kind of
scary to begin with,
because people don't
really understand--
MARTIN: How it works.
AUDIENCE: --how it's
making its decisions.
But you'll put in different
factors about the person,
and that can help inform the
judge as to whether they should
be let out on bail or not.
And so I think there's a big--
someone just filed a
lawsuit about that,
since you're not allowed
to face your accuser,
if your accuser is an algorithm.
So we're already
getting into this--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RASHEED: Well, why would you
even start down that road?
AUDIENCE: Well, because--
the justification--
MARTIN: It's more fair.
AUDIENCE: --whatever
you think of it--
MAX: And it's faster.
AUDIENCE: --is that there
are a lot of judges who are
seeing hundreds of cases a day.
A lot of things are affecting
their judgment from--
I think the paper I read said
it could be like a therapy,
or a team won the night
before, or they're
hungry-- like they're influenced
by these outside factors.
So if we automate
it, then we take
out some of those
biases and other biases
that judges just have inherently
from whatever their upbringing.
RASHEED: Or like
compassion maybe?
I don't know if
there's a compassion--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: It's a very hard--
MARTIN: I mean,
also the way I would
think about it is,
great, because you
get a nice heuristic.
And if there's ever
an issue, that's
the one that goes to court
and will get a full thing.
Because there's
probably a lot of issues
that are very quick cases.
But there's a whole
thing at MIT about this
now that they're doing,
like lawyers and tech.
And it's around Sloan
and around the media lab.
But it's a field that
MIT is looking into,
but I don't know if we'll
come up with a law school.
STEPH: But there was
a really cool study
that I just read for my paper.
I pulled it up.
It got published literally
this week by Carnegie Mellon,
entitled "A Human-Centered
Approach to Algorithmic
Services,
Considerations for Fair
and Motivating Smart
Community Service Management
that Allocates Donations to
Nonprofit Organizations."
So it's a very long title.
But it's essentially--
[LAUGHTER]
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yes, it is.
The title of your paper is going
to be shorter, I'm sure, Steph.
STEPH: I hope so.
So there's three people.
One of them is from the
Center for Machine Learning,
another one's from
the School of Design,
and then there's a stakeholder
from an organization called
Food Rescue, which serves
the greater Pittsburgh area.
And what was really cool
about this was essentially
that they not only talked
to computer scientists who
are designing the algorithms for
who gets the food allocations,
but then they also
evaluated, I guess,
the ethos that was driving the
way that the programmers were
devising their algorithm
and the decisions
that they had made, like
the cost-benefit analysis
and who actually gets the
food, why they should get them,
what considerations their
children should have,
et cetera.
And then from
there, they started
thinking about the ways in which
the algorithm was designed,
how that would impact,
in implementation,
the lives of the people
receiving the food
and whether or
not that was fair.
And interestingly
enough, and I think
that this is really, really
crucial in not only the design
process, but generally in
policymaking, was the question
that they bring
up about empathy.
Like, to what extent
are the algorithms that
are being created reflective
of the individual programmers'
ethics and personal values?
And that was something that
they really bring to light.
And this, I think, is an
incredibly innovative case
study, and it's being applied
to the nonprofit sector
in a really small, piloted way.
But I could see studies
like this scaling
up to other
algorithms and really
striving to understand
the ways in which they
prejudice decision-making,
even if they act as heuristics.
Heuristics are just utilizing
values and shortcuts
to decision-making
based on your intuition
in the decision-making process.
So that could be really cool.
But at the same time,
for me, as someone
who studies both design and
politics, there's an enormous--
and I guess my religious studies
also influence this a bit--
there's a huge movement
in religious studies
to move away from empathy,
because it can be utilized
as a tool for manipulation.
Because if you have insight
into what an individual matters
and what motivates them to
action, then that is not good.
But what, indeed,
you should have,
as was stated by a
divinity professor at Yale,
and I think he also does
some work in philosophy,
is that what you
should strive for
and what I think the
algorithm should strive
for is compassion, not empathy,
which is distinct from empathy.
The difference is
that in empathy, you
seek to feel the way that
the other person feels.
Where in compassion, you seek
to understand how they feel,
but you don't truly try
to access those emotions.
And so I think that
compassion, intellectually,
is more sustainable and is
something that you can actively
implement in an algorithm.
Whereas if you try to make
your algorithm empathetic,
it starts getting into the realm
of making valued judgments,
which is ultimately going
to be damaging and more
prejudicial than if an
individual is making
a decision.
Because then you can leave
the perjury to the machine
and not place the impetus
of whatever discrimination
is happening on an individual.
MARTIN: Also, hacks.
LILY: Always hacks.
RASHEED: Thanks.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
STEPH: Yeah, the Microsoft--
just quickly on that point.
LILY: Mm-hmm.
STEPH: They just released an
article in The New York Times,
I think it was yesterday,
on the hack that
happened in England on the NHS.
And they were wondering,
what is the role
of Microsoft in all of this?
Should they be to blame?
So, a question.
LILY: Well, the whole time I
was watching this, Mindell,
he's brilliant, obviously.
But I also think that he--
I couldn't help but
think that he was
being a little hypocritical.
Because I think his whole
message and premise was
don't worry about
job displacement
by autonomy or robotics,
autonomous robots.
It'll never happen, because
the symbiosis of humans
and machines is more powerful
than the machines alone
or the humans alone.
But I don't think that we can
deny that certain jobs have
been displaced or replaced
by automated machines,
robotics, et cetera.
And although more jobs can
be created in the future
or as a result of
improved technologies,
we can't really get
around the fact, I think,
that the people who do lose
those jobs often have families.
And then, as we've been
talking earlier today,
then they're out of the game.
They don't go back
for a four-year--
an advanced degree--
because, oh,
now I need a PhD or
a master's degree.
They're often permanently
unemployed or displaced
into other service sectors.
So, yeah, David
Mindell, you're right.
We're probably never going
to be completely autonomous.
But then again, there
are jobs-- like,
you can't deny the
fact that there
are jobs that are replaced.
CHLOE: I had the
exact same feeling.
I wouldn't necessarily say
hypocritical, but maybe biased.
LILY: He's never going
to be out of a job.
He's the person
who invents these.
Like, yeah, of course,
he's the one who's
staying ahead of the
technological race,
because he is the
technological race, you know?
[LAUGHS]
CHLOE: But the symbiosis is
very real for the scientists
and engineers whose
limits have been extended
by these types of endeavors.
But for the people
who have never
gotten to that
level of education
in the first place,
yeah, [INAUDIBLE]..
MAX: The thing
is, he pointed out
like, OK, yes, there are people
in manufacturing jobs who
get replaced.
But it's similar to how--
I think it was one of the
other readings, where they were
saying that people who
would have to light lamps
in the street got replaced
by electrical lights,
or people who would shout
news to factory workers
were replaced by radios.
You know, it's going to happen.
LILY: Yeah, it's
going to happen.
But I think he's taking a--
MAX: It sucks, but it happens.
That's how progress works.
LILY: --a self-centric view.
MAX: I don't know really what
to-- what's the alternative,
stop progressing?
Because then other
countries start progressing,
and then you're left behind.
And then everyone's unemployed,
because now your country
doesn't have money.
That's not good.
MARTIN: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE]
or somebody else will.
STEPH: [INAUDIBLE],,
I just wanted
to make a quick point about
the concept of fetishization.
MAX: Fetishization?
STEPH: Fetishization, yeah.
MARTIN: Technology fetishization
or a product fetishization?
STEPH: Yeah, because I think,
at least in my understanding,
fetishization in
post-modern philosophy
is the process by which you
love the idea of something
so much that you
relentlessly pursue it.
And then you continue operating
in the pursuit of that, right?
And the question that--
as much as I love technology
and as I'm fascinated by it,
and as much as I someday
maybe want to be an engineer,
I ask myself, how
is it that we have
come so far in autonomous
vehicular technology,
and we can't get more
public bus routes?
It doesn't seem like a
trade-off to people, but to me,
that's an enormous concern.
And I'm constantly looking up
questions like this on Quora.
And people are like,
well, it doesn't matter,
because they don't have
to be mutually exclusive.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Well,
this is the whole problem
with change in legacy sectors.
How do you introduce innovation
in the legacy sectors?
That's at the heart of
that kind of question.
And changing a public
transportation system,
an established sector,
may, in many ways,
be far harder than introducing
the completely disruptive
technology that's
completely outside the scope
of an existing realm.
MAX: Also, doesn't
this fit in with what
Bill was saying before, where
city driving is unbelievably
difficult, and we
probably will never
get autonomous city driving.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Well,
I'm not saying never.
I'm just saying it's--
MAX: Well, it'll take
a really long time.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: This is
more than a decade of a problem.
STEPH: But I guess I'm
curious, why do we view these--
I'm not going to say
nearly impossible--
but these incredibly technically
challenging problems as more
solvable than getting more
public buses on the route?
Why do we have more persistence
and resilience when it
comes to technical innovation?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Because
it's a frontier territory,
and the barriers
aren't in the way.
MARTIN: Yeah, there's
a lot more barriers
for making a train
and how much it costs.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
STEPH: But I'm not
talking about trains.
Literally, public buses.
RASHEED: No, I think you
were trying to get at,
it's like there's no
barrier to figuring out
what the new autonomous vehicle
is, because there's no existing
infrastructure on
autonomous vehicles
that I have to overcome.
Whereas in order to get
new public bus routes,
I have to contend
with the established
system of public bus routes
and kind of go through that.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Interesting.
MARTIN: There was a
start-up that was like Uber,
but for buses, which is
optimized for people's-- huh?
AUDIENCE: BRIDJ?
MARTIN: Something like that.
AUDIENCE: I think
they just went under.
MARTIN: Yeah, it's just
a lot of the financing--
the economic cycle doesn't
churn continuously.
It needs to get spun.
But a quick point--
I think you've brought
a really good point
in terms of the people
writing these papers.
I was at a talk by a
diplomat on Trump in Mexico.
And he had this
really funny term
where he's like, yeah, it's
kind of interesting to read
a lot of these papers,
because a lot of them--
or like when tech
billionaires talk about,
yeah, we're going to do this
and help the [INAUDIBLE] go
to their dinner, he's
like, yeah, they're
kind of like limousine
liberals, which
I thought was a
really funny term,
not to criticize liberals.
But I think the people that
read 10,000-- there's also
a Chinese saying, which is,
much better to walk 10,000 miles
and talk to the people on the
way than to read 10,000 books,
that I think is really true.
Where it's like--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Are you
familiar with that one, Luyao?
Good.
[LAUGHTER]
I wanted to certify--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
LILY: Verified!
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: It's
a great line, Martin.
I wanted to use it myself, but
I wanted to validate it first.
[LAUGHTER]
MARTIN: I liked the
limousine liberals.
And I was like, yeah,
that was pretty funny.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
That's an old term.
That term's been
around for [INAUDIBLE]..
MARTIN: I didn't know.
STEPH: I'd never
heard of that before,
but it makes total sense.
MARTIN: But it does really
classify the Silicon Valley
kind of--
STEPH: Libertarianism?
MARTIN: Yeah.
But I think the big
issue is we really
need to start talking to
the people on the street
and what they're thinking--
what they think about the
issue, rather than just like,
this is what could be.
Also, put it into practice,
because in practice it could
be a lot of different things.
And most people just
want to do good.
And sometimes their words--
I'm clouded by the way
I view those words.
You know what I mean?
STEPH: I'm just really
perplexed by the fact
that people will spend 50 years
trying to develop a technology.
But in two months
or two years, you
can't increase support
for public transit.
That, I think, is to me, what's
insane about the public sector.
AUDIENCE: Maybe
[INAUDIBLE] because
of the nature of the good.
One is public good
and the other one
is marketable, tradable, private
goods, and there's profit.
CHLOE: Also, to tie it back
to one of your earlier points
about how we have these
Snapchat-esque companies,
Facebook-esque companies,
before we have the big players.
And also because
it's easier maybe now
for a group of 20
to 30 scientists
and engineers to
make a Mars rover
and have that to be a
successful mission--
to have a lot of little
things like that,
where they can define how
they want their innovation
to operate before we can then
take that infrastructure that
is established by those
pioneers and apply it
to public good work.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: You
know, interestingly,
Sanjay Sarma makes the
argument-- of MIT--
he makes the argument
that we're not
going to get to anything
resembling autonomous vehicles
until we integrate the
systems we're developing
into the infrastructure itself.
In other words, suppose rather
than trying to make the vehicle
entirely independent of
everything that's around it--
people, everything
that's around--
suppose we integrated the
vehicle into a new set
of smart infrastructure.
So in effect, there are
rails for every car, right?
They just happen
to be cyber rails.
And that would simplify all
kinds of things in the autonomy
project.
LILY: Or like parking
in a parking structure,
where you just get to a dock
and the parking structure
deals with it.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
So in other words,
making the infrastructure
smart in parallel with
making the vehicle smart
radically resolves a lot
of the problems here.
And yet, we haven't
even thought about that.
We're so busy embarked on making
the vehicle totally independent
that we haven't even thought
about a much more logical path,
he would argue,
which is to upgrade
the infrastructure at
the same time we're
upgrading the vehicles.
And he argues, what's
going to happen to people?
Well, you've got a
massive infrastructure
upgrade, which is going to
be heavy employment focused.
It's a significant
kind of offset.
And we have a thought
about doing that.
And that gets into, in a
way, some of the issues
that you're talking about.
STEPH: Yeah.
And what's interesting is that
in the article that I conducted
with the co-founder of
New Urban Mechanics,
he said that the firms that
he has talked to, and NuTonomy
specifically-- not
to, so to speak,
throw them under the bus--
they don't think that
those are considerations
that fall in their domain.
They think that the
market is, at some point,
going to decide these
things for them,
and so they should just worry
on fixing the technology.
But if there's anything
that this class is teaching
us is that we need to
include these considerations
within the research and
development process,
even at the basic
or early stages.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
So, Sanam, how about a closing
thought on David Mindell.
We've had a robust discussion.
Thank you all.
I think everybody got
into it this time, too.
MAX: I love the
under the bus thing.
[LAUGHTER]
SANAM: Yeah, I think it's
interesting that this debate
about autonomous,
semi-autonomous technology
raises some really
philosophical questions, first,
about what we were
talking about--
humans trust and agency
when it comes to technology.
And then also about
what the goals
should be of when we talk
about integrating technology
into deeper and deeper parts of
life, what should the goals be?
How much should there
be intervention on?
And how could we improve
the overall infrastructure?
So I think Mindell,
at some point,
talked about how
this is engineering
at its philosophical best.
So I think that's an
interesting point.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Good point.
Good closing points, Sanam.
All right, one more to
go, and you're back to me.
RASHEED: You saved
the best for last?
[LAUGHTER]
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: You
could be the judge, Rasheed.
MARTIN: That was
such a good line.
[LAUGHTER]
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: But that
is the cover of my next book
written with Peter Singer.
These are both Peter
and I out hiking.
MARTIN: Nice
pictures too, though.
[LAUGHTER]
RASHEED: So he took one of you,
and then you took one of him?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: No, I think
his mother took that picture.
MARTIN: Their new jackets.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: My wife
took that picture of me.
But this is, as you
saw, a chapter that--
it's actually going through
a far amount of revisions
from the version you've got.
But it's an attempt to kind
of wrestle with this movement
here around the future of work.
And this concept
that people are going
to get displaced
by automation, this
has been with us
for a long time.
So the first major
episode is really
in Britain in 1815 around
the Luddite movement,
with weavers smashing automated
looms that are putting them out
of work.
And eventually, a whole
division of the British Army,
like 15,000 British
soldiers, get
pulled in to put down this
pretty significant movement
in Britain.
So that's the first episode.
We regularly go through this
debate about every 30 years,
roughly.
In 1950, I mentioned
this before,
but Norbert Wiener painted
this very dark vision
of computers displacing people.
It took us a long time to
evolve into Licklider's vision.
In the 1960s, there
was huge anxiety
about workforce automation, as
a number of new technologies
are being introduced into
the industrial processes.
In 2015, that concern
came right back,
that a mix of artificial
intelligence, machine learning,
robotics was going to
be very threatening.
This is an old debate.
So the famous economist John
Maynard Keynes once famously
wrote, "Thus we have
been expressly evolved
by nature with all our
impulses and deepest
instincts for the purpose of
solving the economic problem.
If the economic
problem is solved,
making will be deprived of
its traditional purpose."
In other words, our
lives are organized
around our work in many,
many important kinds of ways.
And that's how our
lives get meaning.
And if we're blowing up the work
model, what's going to happen?
But the important
point to realize here
is, there's no sign of that yet.
The American workweek is
47 hours at this point.
So we're some distance
away from this.
We have time to reflect
on this, if we ever indeed
come close to that kind
of level of realization.
I just wanted to expose you
to this famous Keynes point,
because Keynes is
thinking about this
in the midst of the Depression.
He's thinking about the
whole future of work.
So the backdrop that
we're facing now
is significant work disruption.
And we've talked a
lot about that today.
Half of the manufacturing
jobs, as we talked back
in class number three, were
lost between 2000 and 2010.
And we saw the data on
median income decline,
and we talked about
the barbell problem.
And Brynjolfsson and
McAfee paint a picture
of technological
job displacement
and describe the accelerating
round of IT technologies
that are headed
towards the workplace.
Now, when we read about
advanced manufacturing,
the fix for the
manufacturing sector
is full of new technologies
like 3D printing
and digital production and
advanced sensors and photonics,
and in advanced materials,
a raft of new technologies
that are also going to
be entering that sector
to make that significantly
more efficient
and get the US back in the game.
That's the whole object
of that exercise, right?
So there is a raft
of new technologies
that is headed from the
IT world and elsewhere
into the workplace
that we're all
going to have to reckon with.
And there are
technological dystopians.
So Martin Ford argues that there
is a system of "winner take all
distribution" that's evolving,
that the technology of software
towards monopoly and the ability
of computers to do more than
they're programmed for-- deep
learning, as it's called--
is going to push
out a whole lower
end, that this "winner
take all distribution"
is going to be very
disruptive in this society.
David Cowen argues
that the country
will be divided by this
technological advance
into two countries.
We'll have a developed
world, and we'll
have an undeveloped world
in the United States.
And indeed, Peter Temin
of MIT, the economist,
has just written a book
arguing that current inequality
in the United States
has reached such a level
that the right
comparison is to look
at developing world
economics in a US context
to understand it for you.
Just for example,
Germany, the lowest
20% compared to the
highest 20%, it's 1 to 4.
In the United States,
the lowest 20%
of the population income to
the highest 20% is now 8 to 1.
That's pretty dramatic
income inequality.
That's a pretty-- that's
different than how the US was
for the previous century.
In their Second
Machine Age book,
Erik and Andrew argue
that the low-skilled
replaced the
middle-skilled jobs that
were displaced by technology.
They argue for tax
policy as a fix here.
Although, as we've discussed
and Rasheed led us into it,
that politically is a
very tough proposition.
There are studies that
project very high levels
of technological
job displacement.
So out of Oxford,
Frey and Osborne
look at occupational
descriptions
and conclude, oh,
47% of all US jobs
have high likelihood of
being replaced by automation.
Rob Atkinson at ITIF has
given a very strong critique
of that study.
He argues that it assumes
a highly unlikely 3%
labor productivity rate-- the
advent of all this automation.
We haven't seen that
since the 19th century.
So don't expect it to happen
anytime soon, Atkinson argues.
They also argue that
Frey and Osborne engage
in a lump of labor fallacy.
In other words, they assume that
there's a fixed amount of work
and that the amount of
work doesn't grow spurred
by these new technologies.
That's what David Autor led
us to understand better,
this whole complementarity.
In other words, there isn't
a fixed amount of work.
The complementarity
can create more,
so that there are larger
net potential gains here
across the economy.
The most realistic study of
technological displacement
so far has been by the
OECD done last summer.
They looked at 22 OECD nations.
And rather than look at
occupational descriptions,
they decided, let's go talk to
the workers that are actually
doing those jobs.
And this went through 22
different OECD countries.
They actually went out and
talked to the workforce.
And they would talk
to people about,
you may have a
particular job title,
but what are you actually doing?
What does your work
actually consistent of?
And of course, it turns out, and
we all surmise this in a way,
people are doing many things
that aren't necessarily
captioned in their job title.
Heaven forbid if somebody
held me to my job title.
Nothing would ever get done.
And we all know this, right?
And that's what the
OECD found-- people
are doing much more stuff than
their particularly narrow job
description may say
that they're doing.
So they concluded over an
extended period of time,
across those
developed countries,
the effect of technological
displacement was maybe 9%.
Now, that's a
significant number,
even over an extended
period of time.
That's a significant number.
But it's not 47%.
In the United States,
the number was 10%.
The range was 6%
to 12%, depending
on what kind of employment
you had in your country.
That means we have
a job ahead of us,
but it's not a nightmare.
It's not something we should
be sleepless over every night
from now on.
There's a recent effort on--
this is not in the book,
in the chapter--
but Daron Acemoglu, another
very noted MIT economist
who does a lot of
work with David Autor
and is a real student
of innovation,
he's a growth economist,
Daron looked at robotics.
And he looked at
job displacement
in the robotics sector.
And he had a pretty useful--
had a good database that
he was working from.
He concluded that over a
17-year period ending in 1977,
a total for the
entire United States
economy of technological job
displacement caused by robotics
was somewhere between
300,000 and 600,000 jobs
over a 17-year period.
That is not a big number.
Job churn in the
United States per week
is something like
75,000 jobs per week.
Look at it in that
kind of context.
So these changes are
going to be significant.
And I would argue
they will occur.
But we may have a time period
that we're able to look at them
and think and plan and act
rather than being completely
disruptive overnight.
So there's a quote
by the vice president
of the Danish Conference
of Trade Unions named
Nauna Hejlund.
Her comment at an
OECD conference
I went to last fall
was, "New technology
is not the enemy of
workers, old technology is."
And what she's saying here
is that the companies most
likely to fail, where
all jobs will be lost,
are those who are not keeping
up with the technology.
That workers have a stake in
keeping their firms current
with current realities.
And here's a chart
that just shows
the rate at which
robots are being
installed into production.
It's actually slowed
fairly significantly.
Now, look, we're in
a process of moving
from old-style,
industrial robotics, which
used to weigh tons and
they were fixed in place
and they had to be
fenced off, because you
didn't want to be anywhere near
them, because they were unsafe.
And they would do
the perfect weld,
and that's all they
could do, on an oil line.
We're moving to a whole
new generation of robotics
that are much more
flexible, that
are subject to
voice command, that
are a radically different
kind of robotics
than the old
industrial robotics.
So some of this data
may reflect the fact
that that new
generation of robotics
is only now just starting to be
thought about and put together.
Max?
MAX: Do you think
that this has to do
with some of the
anxieties that workers
have expressed around
being replaced by robotics?
Like there might be some sort
of correlation, relation there?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
This slowdown rate?
MAX: Yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
I don't know.
I don't think so,
because we don't have
an organized workforce anymore.
We're down to about
11% unionization
in the United States.
MAX: Really?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yes.
So workers don't have a lot
to say at this point in the US
about a lot of these changes.
They don't have a lot of
control over their employment,
frankly, which is
another set of issues.
But the chapter argues
that the most immediate
near-term problem is not
technological displacement.
That's going to be a
longer-term problem.
The most immediate
near-term problem
is what economists call
"secular stagnation."
And that's the
problem we're in now.
And this term was developed
by Larry Summers in 2013
to essentially
describe this situation
that we've got at the moment--
interest rates around
zero and US output
is insufficient to
support full employment.
He's running in 2013.
It's gotten better since then.
But we do have this
structural unemployment,
where a significant number of
people who had jobs no longer
are in the workforce.
That's the problem
that's still with us.
He argues that there
are a series of factors
that affect this, that are
hampering the investment
demand.
So decreasing
population growth--
we can all see that-- a relative
decrease in the cost of capital
goods, excess money being
retained and not used
by large corporations--
so retained earnings
by large companies is
very high at this point.
On the savings side,
there's, he would argue,
excessive reserved holdings
in developing countries
due to, in part, post-crisis
financial regulation,
inequality is a cause here, and
increasing intermediation costs
are all causative factors in
this period of low growth.
We have very low GDP, and we
have very low productivity.
So economy-wide, our
productivity is about 1.12%.
Not a good level, right?
MAX: But we still
have low unemployment.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right?
MAX: But we still
have low unemployment.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah,
we have 4.9% unemployment.
But go back to Rasheed's
barbell example--
a lot of that is
the thinning out
of the center being pushed
to lower-end services jobs.
RASHEED: Also, the labor force
participation rate is too high.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah.
So we have low productivity,
low capital investment,
and a low growth rate, growing
inequality, and a declining
middle class.
These are big problems.
Now, low productivity rate,
low capital investment,
that tells us that automation
is not happening at the moment,
because automation is designed
to increase productivity
and is based on increased
capital investment.
We're not seeing
either one of those,
so that tells us that
we're not entering
a period of radical
growth in automation.
Martin?
MARTIN: So is this just
the US or is it global?
And also, is it taking into
account the industrialization
jobs leaving?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah.
It does take into
account the decline
in manufacturing employment.
This is a US picture
that Summers is painting,
and he's going to propose a US
solution in a second, which is
a major infrastructure package.
But the secular stagnation
is a phenomena now
in European economies as well,
and in the Japanese economy.
So this is a worldwide
phenomena of the developed
world at the moment.
And it's a problem
that you all have.
You're going to have this
future work problem for sure,
but now you've got this one.
AUDIENCE: Do we also
have a aging workforce?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yes,
aging workforce, right.
And that's a powerful
part of this story, too.
OK?
So if you have a population
increase, a 1% year population
increase, that guarantees
you one additional percentage
point in your growth rate.
If you have zero
population increase,
you just pull one percentage of
growth out of your growth rate,
out of your GDP rate.
So that's a phenomena that a lot
of these developing countries
are starting to wrestle with.
And China's going to have
to wrestle with this one
fairly soon.
So here's what
Summers is talking
about in terms of excessive
savings over investment.
Look at the split between
savings and investment levels.
That means we're not investing
our savings in the society,
in the economy.
And Summers identifies this gap.
RASHEED: And in 2008
it's like where?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Right there, right?
Well, that's when
savings falls apart.
But there's still a
big gap in the system.
And investment hits then, too.
I want you to know of this
economist named Robert Gordon,
because you all are
hanging out at MIT,
and we believe that
technological advance is
the most powerful thing ever.
But Robert Gordon paints
a different picture.
And you just ought to be
aware of this debate--
not that he's necessarily right.
This was by far the
best-selling book on economics
for the last two years.
And Gordon's book is
called The Rise and Fall
of American Growth.
He argues that the current
low-growth secular stagnation,
and he uses the
term, is the result
not of insufficient demand, but
of insufficient supply, i.e.
insufficient
technological supply.
So he argues that the
IT revolution is fading
and that we never got as
much out of the IT revolution
as we did out of prior
innovation waves.
This one just wasn't that
big compared to electricity
and compared to railroads and
some of the other big waves
that we've been through.
And that we're locked on
to an innovation wave that
is just not, at this
stage, producing
that much productivity growth.
And he goes into enormous
depth about each one
of these technologies.
So a complete rarity
for an economist-- he
actually has read into
the technology literature
and is looking at what
these intentions actually
were in the second half
of the 19th century
and what they meant.
So it's an intriguing
alternative story,
one that's contrary to
the story that we've
been telling ourselves
for a long period of time.
How do we fix this?
Gordon says that it involves--
fixing societal headwinds is
the best way out of this box.
And improving growth will depend
on educational attainment.
And remember when we
read Goldin and Katz,
we talked about how a key to the
historic American growth rate
was that there's always
a rise in increased
technical requirements
in the economy?
And the genius of
the American system,
at least till the mid-'70s, was
that we kept an education curve
between high school, and
particularly Mass college
education, out ahead
of that, right?
That, in turn-- those curves
are related to each other.
That talent base, as
we know from Romer,
helps drive the
technological base.
If you get a large
part of your economy
out in prospecting or involved
in supporting a technology
advance, the whole
system will do better.
So when we leveled out the
graduation rate at the college
level in the mid-'70s, we paid
a big price in terms of ongoing
technology productivity and
technology advance, as well.
So that's kind of
what he's suggesting.
It's an interesting-- he doesn't
spell it out quite that way.
But it's an interesting idea.
So tackling some of these
underlying social problems,
including inequality,
i.e. bring more people
into the economy, all of
these are fixes, in his mind,
for getting around the fact
that the IT revolution isn't
quite what we hoped for.
Now, what do I think of that?
You know, time will tell.
We're going to find out.
I think it may be we had
the rapid rise, we're
on a more moderate growth
pattern in the IT revolution,
as we talked about we talked
about innovation waves.
And we can only expect
more moderate growth
as a result of that.
But we are waiting for
the next big thing,
for the next big innovation.
So Summers' solution is to
throw money in infrastructure--
and, well, let's do roads--
and that will help
that community
that got displaced in
manufacturing jobs that
aren't upskilling.
That could help them.
But the problem with Summers'
solution, I would argue
and the chapter argues, is
that it doesn't do anything
to address productivity, which
is the heart of the problem.
Getting that productivity number
up, as we know, increases GDP.
It's a key causative factor
behind the growth rate.
And let's get that
growth rate up
and overall economic
well-being will improve,
and you'll have more money
to distribute, right?
Let's at least get that right.
But an infrastructure
program that's
aimed at roads and sewers, we
already have our road system.
We have 90,000 miles
of interstate highway.
We're not going to
get, by repairing it,
we're not going to get
the innovation wave boost
that the combination of
building that interstate system
and internal combustion
engines got us back
in the '40s and '50s.
We're just not going
to get that out of it.
So Summers' prescription of
just doing infrastructure
will help people who
are underemployed,
but it's not going to
wrestle with this underlying
productivity rate, which is
really the problem at hand.
And the alternative
here, the book argues,
is investing in
innovation infrastructure.
In other words,
having a larger view
of what that
infrastructure ought to be
and investing in that.
All right.
That's this text.
And let's take it apart.
Luyao, it's all yours.
I'll go back to the hiking
picture at the beginning.
RASHEED: Everybody's favorite.
MARTIN: So it's the last
16 minutes, pretty much.
So do you want to wrap up, and
then go back to the discussion?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Well, let's let
Luyao tell us some
key observations
about this chapter.
I agree, we're heading
towards the deadline,
and there's some things
I wanted to say, too.
But go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, we
realize there's basically
the competition
of the technology
replacement and the
possible solutions
that we have, and also all
the policy factors that we
want to take into account.
And I think the technology
replacement can actually
be an opportunity for economies
having an aging population.
But at the same time,
the United States
facing low investment
rate and low savings
and low economic
growth is probably
problematic for this
substitution to work well.
So what are the suggestions
that we have to just improve--
maybe this is too general.
Yeah, so what are the--
well, let's talk about this.
So in one of the
suggestions it's
saying by reducing the
number of working hours,
it can actually help to
encourage consumption and help
to solve unemployment.
And how do you guys
like this idea?
MAX: Of reducing hours?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, reducing
the number of working hours.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
France has been
working on this for a while.
LILY: I would love that.
But then I think you always
have the people who--
I mean, how do you enforce it
and how do you regulate it?
Because you'll always
have the people who will
want to work more
hours to get ahead.
That's one of the reasons that--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
That's what Chinese do, I guess.
[LAUGHTER]
MAX: Yeah, you
define when people
start getting paid overtime.
It's not that hard.
And then, make it
so that overtime,
as it currently is, you
have to get permission
from your supervisor in order
to actually get those hours.
AUDIENCE: At most companies,
that's already in place.
If you're going overtime,
you need an excuse for it.
MAX: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: And people just do
it under the table instead.
Because by billing
overtime, you're
admitting you can't finish your
work in the normal hours, so
[INAUDIBLE].
LILY: Yeah.
So in my field, we're
not paid hourly.
We're paid on--
the way that we are
measured is in the output of
publications that we have.
So, yeah, I didn't want
to work until 1 o'clock
in the morning three
nights last week.
But I did, because I had
a paper I had to get out.
And so I can't
imagine, in my field,
an hour limit being in place.
MAX: Well, yeah, but that's
different from a factory
job or some sort of--
MARTIN: Yeah, I think
cultural context is important.
Just like I don't
think it's very--
I don't think I went
into the USC to do less.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
This is not a very American
solution, I would say.
[LAUGHTER]
MARTIN: I would try
to think about-- well,
maybe there's certain sectors--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Because
we are driven workaholics.
MARTIN: Yeah.
It is very much the culture.
STEPH: Well, in
the future of work,
one of the trends I've seen
is people talking about who
is going to lose jobs.
And they always say
that the alternative
is that the people who are
going to gain jobs are creatives
and that it's the
creative economy that's
going to gain the most from
automation in manufacturing.
So there's going to be really
interesting opportunities
in, say, virtual
reality, for people
who are interested in
producing, say, entertainment
specifically for that
technological environment.
AUDIENCE: I think Romer proposed
that there will be more job
placement in the middle class.
And we'll see a higher demand
for high-pay, high-skilled jobs
and low-pay, low-skilled
jobs in this,
and we'll see a reduced
size of middle class.
So in terms of the rising demand
for the low-skill, low-pay
jobs, what would be the
social problems associated
with that kind of future?
RASHEED: Yeah, I think you just
highlighted a pretty important
point that we tried to get at,
which is just this hollowing
out of the middle class.
But more importantly,
the economic models
that we're going to have to
use are not going to be--
now, everyone's
income levels are
distributed relatively
evenly in accordance
to population numbers.
But you have to use models from
different countries and stuff
like that.
It's going to be like an
entirely different way to think
about the economy, because we've
never really had to deal with
an economy where we're
so-- now, we're like--
we've never been bimodal before,
having to deal with like,
we only have
low-skill, low-pay jobs
or high-skill, high-pay jobs.
And on the [INAUDIBLE]
the US sits on,
I don't think we've had
to deal with that before.
And so--
STEPH: I don't think a democracy
has had to deal with it before.
AUDIENCE: I mean, would you
not say that early America
was pretty bimodal?
You had plantation
owners, and you
had the bankers in New York.
Everyone else was pretty poor.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah.
I think there were
times in the later part
of the 19th century where we
had these kind of inequality
numbers, too.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so I think
it was a huge problem--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
But we got out of them.
We got out of them, essentially
by raising the education
level of the entire workforce.
STEPH: And increasing
social labor protections.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yes,
and we did that too.
MARTIN: Yeah, that is a
fundamental assumption
that I think is pretty
interesting-- the assumption
that there should
be a middle class
or that it's natural
for there to be.
Or if that's always
going to be a case.
Not to say it shouldn't
be or it should be.
Just it's interesting
that we have
the assumption that the
fundamentals have always shown
that that should be a thing.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
I think I'd argue
that that's pretty fundamental
to the ethos of the country.
STEPH: The American model, yeah.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Overall,
immigration occurred here,
and social classes
were significantly
reduced in the United States
from the period of founding
until the latter part
of the 19th century
when industrialization took off.
But that it was a pretty
strong middle-class base.
And that talent base, that
involved base, that citizen
base, is pretty
key to the effect--
the ability of
democracy to function.
And what happens
in democracy when
you start to really
split the society
and significant
inequality occurs?
I'm worried about some
of this signaling system
we're getting on
that at the moment.
MARTIN: Yeah.
I think it'd be interesting
to do a comparison
to another time in history--
STEPH: Like feudalism?
MARTIN: Well, yeah, just to go--
I mean, [INAUDIBLE] from there,
because we definitely are
living in interesting times.
AUDIENCE: But intuitively,
after learning economics
for several years, I think
raising the labor mobility is
probably one of the solutions.
So how do you guys feel about
how effective would this be
and how feasible would it be?
MARTIN: Labor mobility?
AUDIENCE: Raising
labor mobilities.
MAX: Doesn't that increase
inefficiency, though?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Well,
we've decreased labor mobility
in the United
States significantly
in the last several decades.
RASHEED: Wait, define
labor mobility--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: The
ability to move up in--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, once they
lost their employment,
they can move to
find new employments
with a new set of skills.
RASHEED: Got it.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
But what happens in these
failing industrial economies
is that people--
homeownership is typically
a family's key asset.
If the community is failing
because of industrial decline,
that asset collapses.
It's much harder for people
to get out at that point.
So there's been
less labor mobility,
and interestingly, less job
churn in the United States
in the last decade.
And then there's
social mobility,
which arguably has been
pretty key to this country.
In other words, your
ability to improve yourself,
which has always been
an operating assumption
in the United States.
You could always do better
than your parents, right?
And that may be coming
to an end, as well.
That may be significantly
forward closed.
MARTIN: They've shown
that this generation is
worse off in real numbers
than their parents were.
Or they're less likely
to do what they do.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Fortunately,
you have more stuff.
That's the one really--
MARTIN: Yeah, there's
a saying where,
if you could choose
to be alive today
and be poor, or
be a billionaire--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: We may
be poor, but we got iPhones.
MARTIN: --like a
multi-millionaire.
Yeah, it's like you're
a rich-poor, right?
It's like, yeah, I
can't afford anything.
But I got my phone, I got--
MAX: I got beams.
STEPH: Actually, interestingly,
in terms of memes
representing your culture,
I saw a meme last night
that said, why do you think
I post so many selfies?
I don't have a car, I don't have
a house to post pictures of,
so I'm just going to
post photos of my face.
And I think that's really--
MAX: That's so sad.
STEPH: No, I think
that's representative
of our social
opportunities, right?
AUDIENCE: And you
know that millionaire
who was complaining that the
reason that millennials don't
have houses is because
they're spending all
their money on avocado toast.
[LAUGHTER]
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: All right.
So I'm going to
take the opportunity
to do a quick wrap up
of just this class,
because we did the wrap
up of the overall class
at the outset.
But just very briefly here--
Brynjolfsson and McAfee tell
us that the advent of IT
is going to be
significantly disruptive
in the foreseeable future, in
the short to mid-term future.
And it's going to create
significant technological job
displacement.
And David Autor
in his piece "Why
Do We Still Have So Many Jobs?"
responds with a
long-standing set
of thoughtful
economic arguments,
arguing that we can't just
look at the displaced jobs.
We also have to look at the
new complementary jobs that
are coming about and the net
increase in new technologies
and production
that will accompany
these technological
changes, too.
They create a ground
condition that
may make this shift
more manageable.
And Autor also talks
about how our economy--
he looks at
inequality and ties it
to education and
education attainment.
And he argues overall that
this inequality problem
is tied to our education
levels, education
attainment in our society.
It's going to require
significant upskilling
of our population.
And then David
Mindell takes us back
to the, what's the future of
working going to look like?
And takes a deep dive into what
most people view as the most
threatening
territory-- robotics--
and argues that, yes, there
will be technological job
displacement, but the
relationship with robotics
is a complementary
one, that there's
going to be a human
machine symbiosis.
It's going to be a more
complicated picture than just
straight technological
job displacement.
There will be new opportunities
for people in this mix.
And then reading from that
chapter of the upcoming book
that I'm doing
with Peter Singer,
looking through
the literature, we
conclude that the jobless
future is not on us today,
and the low productivity
rates and low investment rates
suggest that it's
not evolving rapidly.
So we may have a
little time here.
And then, meanwhile, we
do have this deep problem
with a low growth rate,
a low productivity
rate, a low capital investment
rate, which is creating secular
stagnation, in Summers' terms.
And that's something
that we need
to get on, because that's
the immediate future.
And then, overall, this general
upskilling of the workforce
serves both purposes.
So let's get on with that.